hi guys
my talk is going to be about a new way
of making changes to the source code
but before i begin let me ask you how
many people
have seen the presentation by brett
victor invents income principle
okay so his main idea was
about the immediate connection between
the source code and the result
let me explain you why is it so
important
my usual workflow and probably yours is
simply the following i make changes to
the code i
run it in browser then i probably have
to recreate the state of application
and then i look at the results and
compare to what i expected
and then i repeat and i repeat
even more times because i cannot always
foresee
and understand what my changes will
result
for instance if i want to say change the
looks or behavior on the button
on a web page i usually go to editor
type in some changes then i save the
file switch to the browser refresh
then i have to scroll down to the place
where a button is look at the button
okay
maybe i have to change something more
then i go to the editor type in change
and save the file
go to the browser refresh scroll down
look at and again and again doing it all
the day
and maybe you're doing the same and
there is two problems here actually the
first is that i waste time
i keep keep repeating and repeating the
same mechanical actions
all the day and i get tired and the
second is
that as i do not have
v8 in my mind or some dom renderer in my
mind
i often do not know what will be the
result and this
makes my ability to to create to play
with stuff
to try things to imagine quite limited
so his idea was that
you make changes and you see the result
immediately in the same moment you make
this change
and let's look how it works in real life
now so here i have my webstorm 5 running
have anybody heard about webstorm
cool so this is the ide for
web development a lot of cool features
nice application
and my project is a simple static page
that i have stolen
stolen from jetbrains website so there
is a
an html5 can you see the code
should i make it bigger
okay and there are some links to the
style sheets
and so on and this is
how it looks like in the browser in
chrome so this is a nice
page with some books on shelves you know
let me put it to the right
so since this page is my now
let me change it so
for instance
i want to change the title like i type
curious
bookshelf and you see that page
is updated instantly it is not refreshed
instead webstorm
replaces the corresponding dom element
while i am typing
to prove that let me do the same with
the tooltip
you see this tooltip
if i scroll down
and i'd like something like curiel
with no page refresh you know
it's just the beginning if i go to css
and let me for instance
change the color
or a wrong one sorry
you see the color changes the same way i
change it on the left
the same for background
i can even use a color picker to pick up
any color on the screen
like this the same is
for for phones
which font would you like more this one
or this one or this one
okay next time
if i want to say give more space
between the books
i can do it here this way
or i can basically use the slider
anybody likes it
this man
or i can make the books dance
hey
cool but this is a not a css conference
not an html conference it's a javascript
conference right
guess what will happen with javascript
let me add some more animation to my to
my web page
let me draw a clock clock is going to be
a simple circle
uh with uh with just a line for the hand
so let me create a canvas at the bottom
some width and height
like this it's going to appear somewhere
below the books
and let me create a new css file
like this so first
let me register a handler
which will initialize the time
like this and install a function that
will
draw the clock
yeah sure
like 10 times a second
wrong place
so usual stuff like
okay so first i need to clear my context
like this and then i need to draw
a circle so it's going to be context
begin path context stroke
and in between i want to say context arc
what's your number
like this there is nothing on the screen
and the problem is that this unload
handler has already been executed
so here i have to refresh my page
okay something is wrong this is probably
the center so i need to say
canvas
cool if i want to say
make this circle more thick
all right the line width equals to five
oops
should be working
let me try it again
in just a moment guys
we are all developers you know
okay anyway it was supposed to be
working
maybe i will try something else
let me try to to draw this hand for the
clock
okay i give up don't want to waste your
time
i'm sorry
oh thanks thanks guys
you got a free license
for the next version so yeah
so i can basically control the thickness
of the line
instantly because webstorm knows how to
replace that function that i change
so now i can play with my code
like change the change any number in any
parameter that i want
you see this line changes while i'm
changing the source code
and this is the direct change to the
source code not the effective dom or
something
so there are both changes the source
code that code that you
keep in your version control and the
code at
the state of the browser and
to wrap up i would say that immediate
connection exists
using webstorm you can have this
immediate connection to html to css
property be it
color or margin or whatever
and javascript as well and
you can try this immediate connection
right now
and i hope it will help you you just
can download a trial version of webstorm
for free and
it's there if you have any questions you
can reach me by email or ping me on
twitter
thanks
does does anyone anyone have any
questions
uh yeah good in front
um when you replace dom nodes according
to the html you've changed do you
exchange everything or just the thing
you've changed or no
only the part that changed and and how
to figure out
what is what there's some code for that
sometimes it's tricky
thanks
so does that support like uh transpiling
from
coffeescript or not not right now it's
on the plan
okay so right now we we can work with
static files
like css and html and sas and less and
all this
all this compiling are on the plan
um so so one of the limitations from
what you were showing was the uh the
window.onload thing
um are there other ones like that or is
is that like the only thing
general limitation is that uh if a
function or
javascript code has been already
executed at the moment you change it
it's gone on the next execution
it's it's new
so we do not replay that the past
actions
it doesn't make much sense
i actually have a question could you
show um the refactoring
support inside webstorm uh what kind of
some kind of yeah for javascript
introduce variable
is there not make much sense
right here extract method is there
or in inline
rename of course i can't remain rename
this one
but this one will be renamed
there's actually many more
cool okay one more question
this will work yes
the question was if i change a name in
one file
would the other files be updated but for
some cases where you don't know
uh if that function is used in another
file
like if if id is not sure
about whether is used or not it will
suggest you to review
the occurrences that you can manually
include them or exclude them
for instance if you reference a function
by just a string literal
it's one of the cases when id is not
sure
what do you mean
cool i think that's it um thank you very
very much carol
thanks
you